très peu de moyens très bonne chose
c'est ce qui fait la puissance de la bd
à la bibliothèque de viroflay une
vingtaine d'enfants ont assisté à un
atelier bd et cinéma présentée par le
dessinateur et réalisateur de yakari
depuis 17 ans xavier qui a comme ici
chaque année la bibliothèque de 2,0 flat
un partenariat avec le festival de bd de
buc et donc on reçoit un dessinateur ou
un scénariste bd qui propose en a tenu
pour les plus jeunes plutôt à l'aise
avec l'univers de la bd les enfants de 7
à 12 ans connaissait tous yakari je lis
yakari
je lis
ces attentats c'est très bien et nous
expliquer comment passer d'un d'une bd
en film après la bd nous expliquer des
croquis les différentes étapes et de
coloriage c'était bien j'ai bien aimé
comment il expliqué et comment savoir
comment était fait des films comment
procéder pour faire la bd
objectif de cet après midi là pour le
réalisateur montrer l'envers du décor
les enfants en garde beaucoup de dessins
animés peut-être certains lisent
beaucoup de bandes dessinées mais il ya
un aspect que les enfants ne connaissent
pas c'est le tout l'aspect un peu
cuisine fabrication secrets de
fabrication et et ça c'est intéressant
la partager je leur montrais pas des
choses mombris goal voilà donc quand on
regarde certaines images que j'ai montré
qu'ils sont des choses qui est nous
notre quotidien dans le travail et qui
est la réalité de ce métier là ils ont
quand même été un je pense qu'il va leur
en restait quelque chose le film yakari
la grande aventure sera projeté en
ouverture du festival de bd du bugue
vendredi 8 octobre à 20h30 au théâtre
des arcades de buc en présence de xavier
giacometti